[Music]
it takes a lot of cash to pay for some
of these transactions this is an
excellent example of very rare time and
sometimes wheel barrels with millions of
dollars and then
the average piece of jewelry in this
room to go from about 20,000 up to maybe
six or seven million dollars there are
times when people are looking at an
entire table full of jewelry in her back
salon and decide to take it all with
them
we have about 1.8 million people visit
this building each year and maybe only a
few hundred have the opportunity to have
an appointment in the salon the
highlights of this room are actually the
jewelry but they've created this amazing
environment which feels very residential
to make our customers comfortable when
they come in here the clientele the
Tiffany salon are basically a person or
people who have an appreciation for the
finest gems in jewelry in the world
sometimes they'll come of a specific
request for a rare gemstone that
gemstone may take years to procure
[Music]
what you have in front of you is
representative of the type of things
that you might see in the Tiffany's
company salon for the people who have
the means to afford a rare fancy colored
diamond there's quite a range here from
3 million to 200,000 1.4 million this is
a diamond cluster necklace with over 33
carats of tiffany quality diamonds if
you wear this to an event and it's a
dimly lit room the necklace you're
wearing will be the brightest thing in
that room for people you have the budget
and they come in and see these unique
pieces that maybe took a thousand hours
for a jeweler to manufacture and that
there's only one in the world when they
see that rarity they take the advantage
to purchase it
[Music]